if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumpster multiple times that
it was
massive dumps that led him to lose the
election
which is just
[Music]
dumps dumpsters
[Music]
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody a massive
dumps cost of the election
what is going on here what is going on
what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
costing the election
what is going on here what is going on
[Music]
gummy dumps dumpsters
[Music]
dump big massive dumps
all right hey everybody it's finally
that day joe biden will be doing his
first official
press conference in about a half hour we
are counting down the
minutes um whatever happens at this
press briefing
you know what will be said on fox news
and right-wing media
it took him too long to do it it was too
short his answers were bad he may be
senile he mistreated the
right-wing people and the crowd you know
we we know exactly what the
narratives are going to be i don't care
about that i'm actually curious to see
a joe biden answer questions including
tough questions
including tough questions they don't
they i expect no
hand-holding and uh kid gloves
for lack of a better term i do want to
announce to everybody and welcome
everybody
um that i have tested
positively from the standpoint of
negative
on my a covid test as many of you know
we will be on break next week
um and as a vaccinated individual i've
made the calculated decision to make a
travel
to do a travel and i have been tested
and really positive results from the
negative standpoint as donald trump said
and doctors actually surprised i got an
email from the doctor saying
he had never seen results like mine and
wanted to know
how was i even able to do it quite
frankly he was unsure
of how how this was even possible um
so this will be a great event i think
it'll be great to hear joe biden answer
questions he's doing another event later
today
and i don't know if um i will be
covering that one we will just see
yeah my doctor called me and he said sir
we've never seen anything like this
before we we don't know how you did it
um most of our patients this is not
something
that they are able to do and then he
said for you
you don't need to flush 10 to 15 times
based on those results so it was a great
conversation overall all right
um i have a bunch of things to play for
you
before i do that i do want to say thank
you to
i am stranded as well as henny baked ham
uh who else here hold on ellis's
signed up via twitch odwdinc
has gifted five putting us at eight
and zero plus eight is
eight so that puts us there also
very important announcement today is the
last day
for the immoral 21 coupon code and we
actually
and the reason we're uh canceling it
is we are now under investigation i
gotta i have a voicemail from the police
to play
momentarily as far as what's going on
with that okay latest numbers we have a
story on today's podcast about this
cases are going back up in the united
states and if you look now at the
average we had dipped all the way down
to about 55 000 cases a day
um about 10 days ago case is now going
back up we are up
about 3 000 cases a day to 58 000 a day
and i i won't go into all the reasons
why this is happening
part of it is as more people get
vaccinated
many people's perception of the risk
goes down
so they even though they're not
vaccinated they start behaving less
responsibly
variants are a factor so for example let
me see if i can pull this up michigan
in michigan the british variant also
known as the b117
variant is
spreading and although the b117 variant
is very well handled by our vaccines
most people still aren't vaccinated
and thus look at this a 250 percent
increase in cases or
even more uh in michigan that's not good
for now deaths continue to go down
here's usa
deaths still going down but starting to
level okay so we've got to keep
pushing vaccination forward here is the
latest vaccination data
we are at two and a half million doses
per day we had
yesterday 2.25 million doses and
reportedly today joe biden will be
announcing a new goal
of 200 million doses in his first
hundred days his first
promise was a hundred million it wasn't
that ambitious we were already doing
900k when he announced it i know some
people get mad when i say that
doesn't matter he's under promised and
over delivered and that's a really
really great thing
so new announcement coming today thank
you to
tangela irene as well as i am stranded
for gifting five subs that's six
hsc mace has get has signed up for a
seventh
subscription and then a danish joint
just got an
eighth um an eighth subscription
everybody careful
that's eight plus eight to sixteen
is a fantastic number a few other
super chats coming in danny says deepak
don't have the time to watch both you
and sam
cedar so behind on videos i've been
watching yours first
victim of the sam to david pipeline the
pipeline goes goes both ways
no question about that the andrew fox
music channel says my project this
weekend write a david pakman show themed
theme song nice xanadu wants me to spell
red let me see here red r
e d
did i do that correctly
dereten says fox has the flag at
half-mast behind biden pathetic
yeah i don't know what that's about who
knows what the explanation is
but uh soon soon we will be seeing uh
joe biden
chris says hey at home recovering from
covid
you're a welcome relief from terrible
daytime tv thanks chris i hope you're
feeling better
and on the mend also want to say thanks
to major blazer
and blue moon maiden just gifted five
subscriptions via twitch
that's six sixteen plus six six plus six
is twelve carry the one one plus one is
two
is my math right there i think it is
also thanks to nzn8 for signing up via
twitch new member
number 23 today and a big thank you to
makosen for gifting 10 subs
via twitch that's very generous
i do have an unban request to adjudicate
i have my gavel here so we are gaveling
in
uh twitch has a functionality where if
you get banned
you can appeal the ban and argue
that you should be unbanned this one's
kind of a this one's concerning
this is a user named thomas j
thomas first appeared on our channel
in february where thomas said david
i have this rash what do i do
one month later on march 23rd
thomas j came back with the same joke
david can you give me advice about this
rash
thomas came back yesterday and again
said hey david i'm still struggling with
this rash
they then went on a sort of tear
where they just sent messages that are
all capital o's
together oh ooh respect the fish
oh respect the fish oh respect the fish
a minute later again then again ooh
respect the fish
they were then banned and their unbanned
message is come on man oh respect the
fish
please unban me that is just so stupid
that it is going to be denied and
confirmed
that is a perma-ban and we have
adjudicated that one it's just too
stupid i just don't have the patience
for this
idiocy all right so that is the only
unban
request that i have a couple of people
saying the coupon code
isn't working the coupon code is working
fine
and in fact it's the second to last day
for the coupon code remember that
everybody knows about uh better 21
we have an unpublished coupon code oh
wait a second bad gateway
oh no there we go we have an unpublished
coupon code which is immoral 21 so let's
say i want to do
yearly 60 dollars but then i come down
to coupon code
immoral 21
it's processing
oh my god can you imagine if it's
actually not working for once
someone just used it though how could it
be not working
i think this is a one-time website
glitch of some kind
hmm it might genuinely not be working
immoral 21
oh there it is okay that yeah there it
is look at that savings that's a 69
saving 60 dollars becomes 1860. so there
it is yeah just a glitch
just a glitch everything's working fine
coupon code working now
as of midnight tonight uh tomorrow night
the coupon
will not work because we're canceling it
all right
here's a couple of voicemails that came
in actually about the coupon code
the police from our old stomping grounds
in northampton massachusetts did call me
the coupon code is under investigation
listen to this this is sad actually
this message is from mr pakman this is
officer riviera mcgruff
riviera mcgruff that's uh i believe that
they're actually a police captain
the northampton police department i'm
calling really as a fan
you know there's a lot of talk around
the precinct about
upcoming illegal and immoral discounts
i just want you to know we can't let
this
go unchecked right it's completely
unconscionable
i'm a fan but you know that we'll have
no choice
but to act you know i really want to let
you know yeah i shouldn't like the
if the coupon code's illegal it
shouldn't be allowed just because the
police is
the police are fans you know that would
be wrong as a fan
we know what's going on we've heard
about it
it's funny also to refer to the precinct
because northampton's so small there
aren't precincts there's like just the
police station
there's no precincts aware and we're
prepared
so i want you to know that may god bless
you
god bless israel god bless palestine
and may god bless the united states god
bless
the united sheish yep that's true so
that's going on
and then here's another one a lot of
people very reactive to these coupon
codes
hi david this is clay i've been a long
time member but
a big thing that i've always liked about
the show and just about you
is your integrity and i think you're
just a guy of good moral standing
generally but with this new coupon code
of moral 21 and this one day deal coming
up
uh that i i don't know i i think just
the immorality of it
is really throwing you and the entire
show just just just the integrity of it
into question and i'm really rethinking
my membership
yep the membership is too it's so it's
such a good code people are canceling
and where i'm uh supporting media so i
uh
i don't know i i guess i'm just asking
you to rethink all of this and
uh yeah hopefully hopefully you'll come
around and get back to the integrity of
the show
i hope so but uh yeah i i guess i'll
just uh be watching out for that
yep so a lot of people very very um
troubling
troubled by that um
okay and i do want to say thanks but in
all seriousness
i actually now this is not a joke i want
to say thanks to ryan benitez who just
did sign up using the coupon code
immoral 21
on my website joinedpakman.com some
other super chats coming in
dalton says so disappointed the new
immoral discount code is the next victim
of the radical left's cancel culture
war as of tomorrow yep basically
and buffalo five knives says gotta say
beta male is the best track hands down
we'll be enjoying a finca elorigen
from mendoza with a steak this evening
viva argentina
yeah there's some nice uh there's some
great i've been down to mendoza
argentina um let me see if i can even
find some pictures of the winery i think
yeah this place this place is wild this
is a fantastic
uh vineyard in mendoza
it's at the foot of the andes you can
see the andes in the background and they
have this glassed in
dining area i mean imagine go you know
this is all pre-covered
where you can get like a wine lunch
it's absolutely fantastic this place is
really good
and there was one other i went to that
was really good
it's just an amazing amazing place yeah
this is the view
and had a nice little stick shift
vehicle rental
uh was zooming all around just a great
great area
um yeah the entire area
is just amazing these are not like
doctored pictures this is just what it
looks like there it's unbelievable this
bridge i don't remember
going on but a very very interesting
i don't know who this is really really
nice okay so highly recommend it mendoza
tourism when it comes back argentina
great great place to go
um pepe xanadu says is the u.s the most
racist country against all ethnicities
no you know there's these people like um
dennis prager
who like to say the us is the least
racist country in the world i don't
believe the us is the least racist
country but there is no question
that we are way ahead in the u.s on a
lot of racial issues
from where many countries are there
and i think that it's very easy as
progressives to just say
there's no more racism problem that's
bigger than the the united states
it's not the case it's not the case the
u.s actually is way
better on a lot of issues related to
race than many other countries doesn't
mean we have huge problems to solve
but i think it's important not to be
hyperbolic on that
we are seeing massive membership dumps
i want to say thank you to bakari hassan
bakari hassan is a new member andrea
larson has signed up on my website
patricia new is a new member
maximilian frolick is a new member
joe fox's new member number five amanda
abbott is number six charlene campbell
is number seven
jacob durham is number eight charles
hess is number nine
isaac grant is number ten nicholas
is number 11 and gilbert stuber
is number 12. 34 plus 12 puts us at
46. we also have via twitch
a membership from heldardo chaotic
stasis
moon river a web
and i think that's it okay yeah that's
four putting us at 50.
we have a new meme contest if you would
like a
free membership i have 10 free
memberships available
two of which are being underwritten by
let me make sure i get this right
luke ellis luke ellis is has
underwritten
two of these 10 memberships we did a
a meme contest last week we have a new
one and i have a submission
here is the new meme format doing a
david pakman show
edit of this infamous video
[Laughter]
as i said yesterday i could be replaced
for biden's face or trumps or the cat or
something different now i have for you
today
from nick the first submission
if people are remember i have 10
memberships to give away
so don't be intimidated by this but this
is the first
submission and i'm warning everybody
it's very very good
okay if by oh for people who want the
source video
you just go to youtube.com and search
for trump biden bongos and it'll be the
first thing that comes up you don't need
a link we don't need a link
you just go to youtube and you search
for trump biden
bongos okay here is the first submission
from
nick this is what we're up against
[Laughter]
[Applause]
guess what i got a fever
and the only prescription is more
cowbell
it was a perfect storm really
welcome to san francisco mr
[Music]
[Music]
and our buckowski oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
let me recover my ears for one second so
that's a pretty strong first submission
guys
i'm not gonna lie that's pretty good the
only thing
i might tweak is my uh my you know
[Music]
it's a little bit off it's a little bit
off sync
[Music]
it's almost like it's not even off by
half a beat it's off by like a third of
a beat
which sounds a little weird
[Music]
so that's really good that's really
really good and
you can submit yours i think the easiest
way is upload it to youtube and send me
the youtube link so we don't have to
send around files or anything like that
but that's that's really good if you
think you can't do something better than
that don't worry because i have 10
memberships to give away that's only one
submission
okay and some people are saying that
it's out of scope that it should just
stick to the format there's no rules
here
you can as long as it includes the video
um
anything goes and it's up to us to
decide that's it's a very strong meme
really really strong meme all right guys
so that's that and
people can send their submissions to me
info davidpakman.com
some super chats coming in
live breaking pepsi and peeps
collaborating and have made marshmallow
soda they're not calling it
peepsy this is not a joke i i don't i
don't drink soda so i couldn't tell you
what's true and what's not in the soda
world
it is funny that in canada no one cares
about the legality of the coupon code i
know
i know um trudeau has bigger bigger fish
to fry
did i experience racism growing up no
i mean i moved to the u.s and i'm white
i think i definitely let's see i'm
trying to think
before i spoke english and i had like a
spanish helper
maybe there were some people who were
who were you know joshing me for that
the joke was on them though i pretended
this is an incredible story
we moved to the u.s in august right not
this past august i mean the year that we
moved to the u.s it was in august
and started school in september and
by december my parents could tell that i
already understood english and had
no re i didn't need the translator any
longer but i
pretended to need the translator because
i just liked it and she stuck around
until march
can you imagine i got three to four
extra months of uh
translator by pretending not to
understand what was going what
um so that was that was that that was
interesting that was a while ago
that was a while ago um i do have other
new
members to thank brian john just signed
up at joinedpakman.com with the coupon
code
immoral21
aaron burkompus just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
christopher vazquez just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
john faso is a new member
tom miller is number five wait benjamin
vazquez
benjamin and christopher vazquez signed
up i don't know if they're related
that's number six
and christine batura is number
seven putting us at 57. we do count
twitch subs as well
so cosmos 84 as well as iloitsi
grizzly adams ninja of physics
have dropped in some twitch subs putting
us at
61. uh
other super chats oh people are asking
if my parents were mad that they were
paying for the trans
the translator this was you know this
was a long time ago the translator was
provided by the school
didn't even no we weren't paying for it
it was free at the point of service i
guess we were paying for it via taxes
right
kieran buckley says hi david fan from
the uk really enjoy the content
and keep up the great work thank you
kieran i appreciate that
white death says have you reached out to
interview any uyghur activists
yes we did uh they didn't write back but
we did reach out to two
one or two ferret says
headed to your neck of the woods
saturday
uh oh new york city
oh my old neck of the woods in boston oh
blue hills common public garden
lunch recommendations nothing crazy yeah
um
let me see if this place is still open
hold
on
yeah here's a place if you're gonna be
around the common here's a good spot for
lunch
sauce this is a belgian sandwich and fry
place
i assume that they're still open
they're open for pickup okay
uh yeah they have um you know they
they have the fries look at these look
at these fry sauces it's a real belgian
style
smoky chipotle spicy sambal
garlic chickpea mayo curry ketchup very
controversial i know
herbed ranch this is a good spot
and they used to have what did i used to
get there
i used to get sometimes a mushroom
grilled cheese seems like that's gone
what would i probably get i've had the
kimchi fried chicken sandwich
strong sandwich very very strong
so that's and they're hiring yeah so
that's something to look at certainly
uh all right there is that
vandal grunt says why do you think fox
is trying to paint biden to see
as a senile incompetent old man um
because they're a right-wing network and
it's getting clicks i don't know
daniel krieger says you were offbeat
with the hammer that's the joke oh you
know what's funny about that i was
worried about that
when i was playing along to the song i
wasn't
offbeat the way i was hearing the song
but i was worried
that there was a slight delay
and that it was melding incorrectly
out there okay thank you
edward says have you seen the original
version of this song
it's a group of four all acapella no i
haven't no i haven't
favorite flavor of crisp potato chips
just curious
i haven't had potato chips in so long i
couldn't even tell you i guess
i guess barbecue i think barbecue
amanda says thanks for the immoral
coupon code i just used it it's very
much illegal and very much working
i was wondering what your favorite
cookie is oh favorite cookie i i'm kind
of like a double chocolate guy
like the the cookie itself is brown and
it has pieces
of chocolate in it i think that's
probably my favorite cookie
did you deliberately make the discount
code 69 i thought this show was pg what
the hell david yeah i don't remember
what it relates to there was some reason
for that
which i forgot i've now forgotten i
tried subscribing but the code q
anon didn't work like it did on my
pillow
that i'm sorry yeah
if you like noise rock bands like the
jesus lizard or shellac
you should check out my band in
nashville shanghai theater i don't even
know what noise rock is and i've never
heard of those bands
how often do you work your arms you look
jacked
yeah thanks anita every day obviously
every day thank you
i do want to say thanks to greg burleson
for signing up on my website also
michael shepherd
signed up at joinpakman.com putting us
at 63.
also want to say thanks via twitch
that's my mitch
just grabbed a sub shello mello
just grabbed a sub that's two putting us
at 65.
what percent is that 65 out of 100
6 divided by 10 is 0.6
carry over square root
we are 65 of the way to our goal
it'd be humiliating if my math was wrong
on that
um daniel says how can i stream the
audio of your live
shows you can't if it's not available
what can i do to help it happen
probably nothing the easiest way to
stream the audio of the live streams
is to stream the video and not look at
the video
that's my recommendation people asking
if we filled the position i
i talked about uh last week no the
we had over 300 applicants and so
we are working through the applications
moving on to the skills test
portion but over 300 applicants to work
through
my guess is especially with our vacation
coming up
um my guess is that
we're it's going to take a few you know
several weeks to go through this but a
lot of excitement
a lot of excitement over the new
position at the david pakman show
twitch has audio only i'm being told
okay very good i stand corrected
so you can do it on twitch i guess
daniel
waffle says are you hodling yeah i
am i am um
i have uh i sold 15
of my bitcoin on january 1
the the point of that was to make it an
a taxable event
on my taxes that would be done in 2022
so on january 1 i did a fifth
weird noise i did a 15
sale and then i've just been holding and
i mean i know things are down a little
bit over the last couple of days
my idea is as i've said before i am not
a financial advisor but
i don't recommend having more than three
to five percent
or at the most eight ish percent of
assets in bitcoin because who the hell
knows what's going to happen
but because you know i'm i don't have a
large share of my assets in bitcoin
i'm basically thinking of it as as a
black swan
um and you know if it were to lose half
of its value
i might cut my losses and sell but
i'm just holding with the idea that it
could be at a hundred thousand per coin
by the end of the year and if it doesn't
it doesn't right i mean it's
it's an asymmetrical risk where if it
went to zero
i'm talking three to five percent of my
assets
but if it doubles or triples then it's
significant then it's significant
not financial advice not financial
advice obviously
let's see here david how likely is it
that dominion will sue trump as a
private citizen
no yeah it's not gonna happen i don't
think they're gonna do that
jack another attempt to get me to by the
way do people know about that
bill o'reilly clip let me see if i can
find it
bill o'reilly
it's the mr mayerhoffer clip
where is this yeah
this is so good every time i see that
i'm reminded of this
jack mayhoffer springfield massachusetts
says o'reilly i see the new fox
definition
of fair and balanced mean how did it get
by everybody
how does it get by every single person
working for this show
jack mayhoff or springfield
massachusetts says o'reilly i see the
new fox definition affair and balance
means
interviewing dnc chief jerry mcauliffe
at both conventions
well right you are mr mayor hoffer mr
mayerhoffer with a really really
important message there for bill
o'reilly
um jack says how would you describe your
day-to-day scent
uh i have no idea mountain fresh i think
the coupon code makes the yearly price
21
is why that's for better 21.
not for immoral 21.
joel says which country are you from i
am from argentina
so when can we expect an end video ad
for my pillow we will not be advertised
honestly i would be interested in
getting as an advertiser
a competitor to mike pillow a different
pillow
so if we can find a pillow advertiser i
would love that
and to compete with mike pillow
i want to say thank you to derek leland
for signing up at joinedpakman.com
tom hamel has signed up at
joinedpakman.com
jacob janick has signed up at
joinedpakman.com and
darren chappell has also signed up
putting us at
69 new memberships for the day
69 of the way
we are now officially standing by for
joe biden
scheduled for now scheduled for now
bilbo baggins says can you give a shout
out to my friend
andrew he's a teacher and a huge fan of
your show
absolutely andrew thank you keep up the
teaching
i love it and um
hope you're vaccinated all of that stuff
james says who's your favorite member of
the insane clown posse
i have i couldn't name a single
individual
what are they called uh
juggalos what are the icp people called
i forget what they're called juggalo
juggalos yeah um extreme instinct
sends a super chat saying we are live
and urgent yes the much
anticipated first ever official press
briefing of joseph r biden jr
we are commemorating this by ending our
unpublished coupon code tomorrow
better 21 that's for the amateurs
the pros know about the unpublished
coupon code
immoral 21 but it does end tomorrow
respect says ravioli ravioli
give me the formulae
i don't know if that's some kind of
inside uh
that's a pretty nasty question william
legate and david hogg
have a new pillow company to run my
pillow out of business
it's called good pillow you should reach
out yeah
i don't think that they are um
i don't think that they are like in the
in the position of doing advertising yet
but that would be interesting seems like
the fight for dc statehood is gaining
momentum could it happen during biden's
first term yes it could
i would assess it as having about a 30
percent chance
rocco says david we yearn for the
merchandise perhaps so what does this
mean
absolutely nothing or massive dumpster
make it happen my king
oh that's an important announcement
david pakman show
merchandise is back we shut down
the store because of covid we everything
was getting delayed and we couldn't get
anything shipped out
we're back on fully people are getting
their stuff so we've got the data mail
t-shirt of course that's a perfect
t-shirt people like that
um we have you can get it in all sorts
of different colors i kind of like
tahiti blue
it's just me um the coffee
mugs are back various sweatshirts
we have this one's edgy this is the if
ivanka weren't my daughter
t-shirt that one's popular in banana
cream i don't know why but people like
that one in banana cream
um yeah we need some new stuff
we need because a lot of these are still
trump themed
the very stable genius that's nice
what color is this one good in
it's not bad it's actually that's a nice
contrast in banana cream
honestly i think every shirt is best in
banana cream
but yeah we are um those are shipping uh
globally and everything is back on if
people have design ideas we'll make it
into a t-shirt if people want it
no doubt about it so that's back on
davidpakman.com
gear and also if you're on on youtube
the
the t-shirts and stuff that appear
around this the video
that vendor never shut down for covid so
those are
those are those have continued to be
available
soberdude says david pillow cube is up
and coming
all right i'll look into that jace's
ravioli ravioli great barrier reef
is this the tallest you've ever quaffed
your nice hair
no no no i mean it's my i just got a
haircut the other day
it's not even possible of going high
really
right now
um okay
jamie says david you should listen to
mac miller good news
cody manhart says data
cameron mccabe says is there a massive
dumps t-shirt
no that would be an interesting design
some kind of massive dumps
t-shirt we would we would run with that
flan from powderbox all-time favorite
from childhood please
don't ban oh my god is that like an
instant flan
let me look that up
oh my goodness i'm sorry but i might
have to ban you for this
these are like oh this is like factory
flan
it's boxed flan
oh this is depressing
oh and this is a flan style custard
that's not even flan
oh my god how is this even legal to be
sold
the second ingredient is carrageenan
oh my god i don't even know what to make
of this never ever
ever buy that please never buy that flan
is three ingredients
okay milk sugar and eggs that's it
you make some caramel you get it dark
but not burned and you put it at the
bottom of the pan
and then it's milk eggs and sugar in the
oven for an hour
that's flan carrageenan
that is depressing guys that is
seriously depressing to see
i won't ban you pepe but i am concerned
david check out pillow cube advertising
on youtube and looks legit
pillow cube
interesting i'm going to send an email
to noah right now actually
pillows hey we should look for
a pillow advertiser in particular
because with
all the my pillow stuff going on
we have a great pitch about
don't fall for the right wing pillows
which stink anyway we wouldn't
use that language but in any case
let's see if we can find a pillow
sponsor
we're making it happen guys
yeah i don't mean noah that works for us
i just mean you know noah watching on
twitch
okay other super i'm sorry other new
members i want to say thanks to david
carey
as well as craig fyfe jackie ott has
signed up
carmen valli riestra is a new member
gerard durkin has signed up john
chipolini is a new member so is dan
zuniga that's number seven
jason lutner lutmer is number eight
and ian foster is new member number nine
that's putting us at 78.
also oh look people are making some uh
gear orders that's cool
yeah it wasn't we didn't ever want to
shut down the gear store it was just
that
things weren't getting to people uh
so that's that big thank you also via
twitch to beef goggles for the new
twitch sub
andrew whiplash has signed up sergeant
bus
is a new member putting us at 81.
if you're just joining us you've missed
nothing we are standing by for joe
biden's press conference
scheduled for seven minutes ago and
hopefully we'll start soon
franz says love your crisp enunciation
excellent diction
thank you franz
charenco asks why is fox news so
bothered that it took this long for
biden to do a press conference
they just need drama that's all it is
they just need drama
thoughts on the snyder cut snyder cut i
don't know what that means
if you can give me more info i would
address it
people asking about the new emotes we do
have new emotes on twitch we have a
bitcoin emote it's me with laser eyes
we have a beta emote and we also have a
david chadman emote not all of these are
available
to everybody for some you do need to be
a
uh a sub what do you use in your hair
yeah i've addressed this before it's
this is not a sponsor i use a product
called
uh fiber made by the
company american crew it's insanely
expensive but it's the only thing i've
been able to find that can get my hair
under control
and it really lasts a long time a little
bit goes a long way
not a sponsor should randy rainbow
remove his
love ballad about cuomo do you think
it's aged well
i'm in love with your skater boy look oh
my god
i haven't seen the randy rainbow cuomo
video
so i would not be able to say ed
says what pomade or hair product do you
use okay yeah
american crew fiber
not a sponsor but they should be wendy
says
boxed flan is an abomination and is just
wrong
pepe xanadu says have flan ready in the
fridge from last night
you know i have to tell you the truth in
argentina the tradition is the flan
you have with the dollop of dulce de
leche if it weren't for the dulce de
leche i don't know that flan would be
that good
that's the latest hot take
uh kazeem says save the powdered flan
guy yeah i won't i won't ban him but i
am
i am upset about it you should bring
youtube boxing into politics and box ben
shapiro that's an idea it's not not a
bad idea
i don't know that anyone would pay what
i would need to be paid to do that
but i think it's an interesting idea i
would consider it if the money was right
um don king will be representing me in
the negotiations
just found your channel when is the
coupon going live
it's live right now it's immoral 21 the
it's not when is the coupon going live
it's when is it ending
it's ending tomorrow thank you to
jose castillo for signing up at
jointpakman.com
thanks to stephanie cripps for signing
up
thanks to kaylee killian for signing up
at joinedpakman.com
that's three putting us at 84.
joe biden is late
but we will see when this starts i also
want to say thank you to
unlikely gamer for the twitch sub koirai
david g pool
okay yeah just those three putting us at
87.
um really want to compete with my pillow
promote crack
yeah that's we want to stay within the
terms of service
how does an impeachment work for
governor cuomo i don't know how new york
state impeachment works that's a good
question and i don't i don't have the
answer
why it says design a pillow with a
stereo bluetooth speaker built in
that plays bedtime stories using a deep
fake trump voice that's a lot of work
i'll leave that to someone else to
design
but i like the idea thoughts on the nba
trade deadline today
no no basketball hot takes today but i
have been watching more basketball
lately
i have been getting back into it what
was up with house republicans and the
free brittany nonsense
i have no idea i didn't know they were
talking about that
zack snyder is an ein rand shill
all right manooki says
what do you use for your hair american
crew fiber
american crew fiber
roberto says venezuelan flan
that sounds communist i don't know about
that
let's see what venezuelan flan is
okay it's almost like a cheesecake
white sugar condensed milk milk and eggs
okay so it's like argentinian flan
flan but with condensed milk
all right
don't know too much about it but it's
interesting i'm nervous for biden are
you
not really mostly because i don't care i
mean it's like
i just oh here we go
good afternoon before i take questions i
want to give you a progress report
to the nation on uh
on where we stand 65 days into office
here
on vaccinations and a few other top
priorities for the american people
first on vaccinations on december 8th
i indicated that i hope to get 100
million shots in
people's arms in my first 100 days
please please we met that goal last week
by day 58.
let me mute this out hold on there we go
now today i'm setting the second goal
and that is we will by my 100th day in
office
have administered 200 million shots wow
people's arms that's right 200 million
shots in
100 days i know it's ambitious
twice our original goal wow but no other
country in the world has even come
close not even close to what we're doing
i believe we can do it and today
we made a historic investment in
reaching the hardest hit
and the most vulnerable communities the
highest risk communities
as a consequence of the virus by
investing an additional
10 billion dollars in being able to
reach them
i also set a goal before i took office
of getting a majority of schools
in k through 8 fully open
in the first 100 days now thanks to the
enormous amount of work done by
our administration educators parents
local state education officials and
leaders
recent department of education survey
shows that
nearly half of the k-8 schools are open
now full time
five days a week for in-person learning
strong you had a majority
but we're really close and i believe in
the 35 days left to go we'll meet that
goal as well
as of yesterday more than 100 million
payments of 1
400 have gone into people's bank
accounts
that's real money in people's pockets
bringing relief
instantly almost and millions more
will be getting their money very soon
one final note since we passed the
american rescue plan
we're starting to see new signs of hope
in our economy
since it was passed a majority
a majority of economic forecasters
have significantly increased their
projections
on the economic growth that's going to
take place this year
they're now projecting it will exceed
six percent a six percent growth in gdp
and just this morning we learned the
number of people
filing for weekly unemployment insurance
pandemic life by nearly 100 000
persons it's the first time in a year
the number has fallen below the
pre-pandemic
high so there are still too many
americans out of work
too many families hurting and i still
have a lot of work to do
but i can say to you the american people
help is here and hope is on the way
now i'll be happy to take your questions
here we go
zeke associated press
thank you mr president you mentioned
your progress on combination i'd like to
ask you about some of the other
issues uh facing your press i'm gonna
switch streams so that we can see the
reporters okay
and i still have a lot of work to do
it's a little bit delayed the white
house feed is always delayed but in
general we can see the reporters i think
that that's better okay
and hope is on the way now i'll be happy
to uh
take your questions
zeke the associated press
thank you mr president you mentioned
your progress on cover 19 i'd like to
ask you about some of the other issues
uh facing your presidency one of the
defining challenges you face in the
coming months
is how to deliver on your promise to
americans on issues like immigration
reform
gun control voting rights climate change
all of those right now are facing stiff
united opposition from republicans on
capitol hill
how far are you willing to go to achieve
those promises that you made to the
american people
well i'm good look when uh
when i took office i uh
decided that it was a fairly basic
simple proposition
and that is i got elected to solve
problems
and the most urgent problem faced the
american people i stated from the outset
was covet 19 and the economic
dislocation for millions and millions of
americans
and so that's why i put all my focus in
the beginning
there are a lot of problems but all my
focus on dealing
with those particular problems
and the other problems we're talking
about from immigration
to guns and the other things you
mentioned are
long-term problems they've been around a
long time
and what we're going to be able to do
god willing
is now begin one at a time to focus on
those as well
and whether it's immigration or guns or
a number of other problems that face the
country but the fundamental problem
is getting people some peace of mind
so they can go to bed at night and not
stare at the ceiling wondering whether
they lost their health
insurance whether they're going to lose
some family member
whether they're going to be in a
position where they're not going to be
they're going to lose their home
because they can't pay their mortgage or
the millions of people are going to get
thrown out of their homes because of
the inability to uh to pay their rent
so we're we're going to move on these
one at a time
try to do as many simultaneous as we can
but that's the reason why i focused as i
have
and here's the deal i think my
republican colleagues are going to have
to determine
whether or not we want to work together
or they're
decide that the way in which they want
to proceed is to
is to just decide to divide the country
continue the politics of division but
i'm not going to do that i'm just going
to move forward
and take these things as they come
follow up mr president
can your presidency be a success if you
can't make progress on
those four challenges climate change
immigration reform gun control
voting rights well i plan on making
progress on all of them but that's going
to be for the american
people to decide i think you know i i
doubt whether
maybe you did maybe others did i i i
thought
many of you thought there was no
possibility of my getting
the plan i got passed passed without any
republican votes
pretty big deal got passed
growing the economy people's lives are
changing
so let's see what happens all i know
i've been hired to
solve problems to solve problems not
create division
uh okay uh how about yamiche
thank you all right mr you've said over
and over again
that immigrants shouldn't come to this
country right now this isn't the time to
come
that message is not being received
instead the perception of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
man is
the reason why a lot of immigrants are
coming to this country and entrusting
you with unaccompanied minors
how do you resolve that tension and
how are you choosing which families can
stay which can can go given the fact
that even though
with title 42 there are some families
that are staying and is there a timeline
for when
we won't be seeing these overcrowded
facilities with run by cpb
when it comes to unaccompanied minors
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
i'm a decent man or
whoever's phrased that you know that's
why they're coming because no biden's a
good guy
truth of the matter is nothing has
changed
as many people came 28 increase in
children to the border in my
administration 31
in 2019 in 2019 before the pandemic
in the trump administration it happens
every single solitary year
there is a significant increase in the
number of people coming to the border
in the winter months of it's smart to
mention the seasonality
it happens every year in addition to
that there
is a and nobody and by the way
does anybody suggest that there was a 31
percent increase under trump because he
was a nice guy
and he was doing good things at the
border that's not the reason they're
coming
the reason they're coming is that it's
the time they can travel with the least
likelihood of dying on the way because
of the heat in the desert
number one number two well done they're
coming because
of the circumstances in country right
in country deal with that the way to
deal with this problem
and i started to deal with it back when
i was a united states senator
i mean vice president for putting
together a bipartisan plan of over 700
million dollars
to do the root causes of why people are
leaving what did trump do
he eliminated that funding he didn't use
it
he didn't do it in addition to that what
he did he dismantle all the elements
that exist to deal with what had been a
problem
and what and has been continued to be a
problem for a long time
he in fact shut down the
the number of beds available he did not
fund hhs
to get people to get the children out of
those
those border patrol facilities where
they should not be and not supposed to
be more than
a few days a little while but he
dismantled all of that
and so what we're doing now is
attempting to rebuild
rebuild the system that can accommodate
the what is happening today and i'd like
to think it's because i'm a nice guy but
it's not it's because of what's happened
every year let me say one other thing on
this if you take a look
at the number of people are coming the
vast majority
the overwhelming majority of people
coming to the border
crossing are being sent back are being
sent back
thousands tens of thousands
of people who are who are over
18 years of age and single people
one at a time coming have been sent back
sent home we're sending back the vast
majority of the families that are coming
we're trying to work out now with mexico
their willingness to take
more of those families back but we
that that's what's happening they're not
getting across the border and those who
are coming across the border who are
unaccompanied children
were moving rapidly to try to put in
place what was dismantled as i said
for example of all the children are
coming across the border
over 70 percent are either 16 or 17
years old
we're not talking about people ripping
babies from mother's arms or little
three-year-olds standing on the border
less than i think it's one and a half
percent fall in the category of the very
young
so what we're doing is we're providing
for the space
again to be able to get these kids out
of the border patrol facilities which no
child no he's handling this very well so
far
72 hours and today i went to for example
i used all the resources available to me
went to the defense department and and
the secretary of defense has just made
available fort bliss
5 000 beds
be immediately available 5 000 beds in
the texas border
so we're building back up the capacity
that should have been maintained and
built upon
that trump dismantled it's going to take
time
and the other thing we're doing i might
add am i giving you too long an answer
because if you don't want the detail
no no but i mean i i don't know how much
detail you want about immigration
maybe i'll stop there in front of you my
follow-up question
is um one if you could talk a little bit
about which families why they're being
allowed to say
what the families that are being allowed
to stay why they're being allowed to say
in addition to that
when it comes to the filibuster which is
what zeke was asking about
there's immigration is a big issue of
course when it related to the filibuster
but there's also
republicans who are passing bill after
bill
trying to restrict voting rights chuck
schumer is calling it an
existential threat to democracy why not
back
a filibuster rule that at least gets
around issues including voting rights or
immigration
jim clyburn someone of course who you
know very well
has backed the idea of a filibuster rule
when it comes to civil rights and voting
rights
well look i'm going to deal with all
those problems
the question is the priorities as they
come and land on my
plate let's go to the first question you
asked the the first of the second
questions
that you asked and that is question two
party
with families why are not some not going
back
because mexico is refusing to take them
back
they're saying they won't take them back
not all of them we're in negotiations
with the president of mexico i think
we're going to see that change
they should all be going back all be
going back
the only people were not going to let
sitting there on the other side of the
rio grande by themselves with no help
are children and what we're doing there
is an important point to understand i
know you understand it i don't mean to
say
it that way important point to focus on
the vast majority of people under the
age of 18 come to the united states
come with a telephone number on the on a
wristband
or come with a telephone number in their
pocket in the united states
a mother a father a close relative a
grandmom or grandpa
what was happening before is this taking
literally
weeks and weeks and maybe even months
before anybody pick up the phone on call
to see if there really was someone there
well we've set up a system now
where within 24 hours there's a phone
call made
as that person that child crosses the
border
and then a verification system being put
in places as of today
to determine quickly whether or not that
is a trafficker being called
or that is actually a mom a dad and or a
close relative
they're establishing that right off the
bat if it in fact is
mom or dad dad says to take the extreme
case i got a birth certificate
then guess what we're getting that kid
directly to
that parent immediately and so
that's going to reduce significantly
there's two ways to reduce
child populations in circumstances that
are not acceptable like
being held at a border patrol station
one is to get them to the place where
they
have a relative and set a date as to
when a hearing can be held
the second way to do it is put them in a
health and human services facility that
we're occupying now
both licensed beds around the country
that exist
as well as for example federal resources
like fort bliss
to get them safely in a place
where they can be taken care of while
their fate is determined
would mexico take rand paul i wonder
you know with regard to the filibuster i
believe
we should go back to a position of the
filibuster that existed just when i came
to the united states senate 120 years
ago
and that is that it used to be required
for the filibuster
and i i had a card on this i was going
to give you the statistics but you
probably know them
that it used to be that uh the
that was from between 1917 and 1971 the
filibuster existed
there were a total of 58 motions
to break a filibuster that whole time
last year alone there were five
times that many so it's being abused in
a gigantic way
and for example it used to be you had to
stand there
and talk and talk and talk and talk
until you collapsed
and guess what people got tired of
talking and tired of collapsing
filibusters broke down and were able to
break the filibuster get a corpsman vote
so i strongly support moving in that
direction in addition to
having an open mind about dealing with
certain things that are
are just elemental to the functioning of
our democracy
like the right to vote like the basic
right to vote
we've amended the filibuster in the past
but here's the deal
as you observed i'm a fairly practical
guy
i want to get things done i want to get
them done
consistent with what we promised the
american people
and in order to do that in a 50-50
senate
we've got to get to the place where i
get 50 votes
so that the vice president united states
can break the tie or i get 51
votes without her and so
i'm going to say something outrageous i
have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done
in the united states senate so the best
way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you uh
um like to be able to
anyway oh boy
i'm we're gonna get a lot done and if we
have what is happening there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
okay um hang on
uh sorry
oh sing me miss kim
all right mr president um to follow up
on the filibuster
so do you believe it should take 60
votes to end a filibuster on legislation
or 51
if we could end it with 51 we would have
no problem
you're going to have to the existing
rule
it's going to be hard to get a
parliamentary ruling that allows
50 votes to end the filibuster the
existence of a filibuster
but
it's not my expertise and what the
parliamentary rules and how to get there
are but
our preoccupation with the filibuster is
totally legitimate
but in the meantime we got a lot we can
do while we're talking about what we're
going to do
about the filibuster it's going a little
less well the last five minutes
okay uh um
cecilia vega
i'd like to circle back to immigration
please uh
you just listed the reasons that people
are coming uh
talking about in-country problems saying
that it happens every year
you blame the last administration sir i
just got back
last night from a reporting trip to the
border where i met
nine-year-old jose who walked here from
honduras
by himself along with another little boy
he had that phone number on him
and we were able to call his family his
mother
says that she sent her son to this
country because she believes
that you are not deporting unaccompanied
minors like her son that's why she sent
him a loan from honduras
so sir you blame the last administration
but is your messaging in saying that
these children are
and will be allowed to stay in this
country and work their way through this
process
encouraging families like joe says to
come
well look
the idea that i'm going to say
which i would never do if an
unaccompanied child ends up at the
border we're just going to let them
starve to death and stay on the other
side
no previous administration did that
either except trump
i'm not going to do it i'm not going to
do it
that's why i've asked the vice president
united states yesterday
to be the lead person on dealing with
focusing on the fundamental reasons why
people leave honduras guatemala el
salvador
in the first place it's because of
earthquakes
floods it's because of lack of food it's
because of
gang violence it's because of a whole
range of things
that when i was vice president had the
same obligation to deal with
unaccompanied children
i was able to get it slowed up
significantly by working with the heads
of state of those
communities to do things like in one of
the major cities
the reason people were leaving is they
couldn't walk the street because they
were getting
their kids were getting beat up or shot
or gang violence
well what i was able to do is not give
money to
the head of state because so many are
corrupt but i was able to say okay you
need lighting in the streets to change
things
i'll put the lighting in we got a
contractor
we got the type of lighting we paid
directly to the contractor did not go
through the government
and violent crime significantly was
reduced in that city
fewer people sought to leave when this
hurricane
occurred the two hurricanes instead of
us going down and helping
in a major way so that people would not
have a reason to want to leave
in the first place because they didn't
have housing or water
or sustenance we did nothing
we're going to do a lot in our
administration
we're going to be spending that 700 plus
million dollars a year
to change the life and circumstances of
why people leave in the first place
that mother did not sit around with on
the kitchen table and
and say you know i got a great idea why
i'm going to make sure my son get taken
care of
is i'm going to put him how old was he
or she
he's nine i also met a ten-year-old
a a nine-year-old i'm going to send him
on a thousand mile journey across the
desert and up to the united states
because i know joe biden's a nice guy
and he'll take care of him
what a desperate act to have to take
the circumstances must be horrible so we
can do something about that that's what
the vice president's going to be doing
what i did when president obama asked me
to come and deal
i was in i was in turkey at the time he
said you got to come home and take care
of this
so we put together a plan and it had an
impact
and so the question here is whether how
we go ahead and do this what we do
there's no easy answer
quick follow if i may do you want to see
these unaccompanied minors
staying in this ch this country or
should they be deported eventually
well the judgment has to be made whether
or not in this young man's case he has a
mom at home
there's a overwhelming reason why he'd
be putting a plane and flown back to his
mom
all right follow sir you mentioned
circumstances that must be horrific
the customs and border protection
facility in donna texas i was there
is that 1556 capacity
right now with mostly unaccompanied
miners there are kids that are sleeping
on floors
they are packed into these pods i've
spoken to lawyers who say that they
some of these children have not seen the
sun in days what's your reaction
what is your reaction to these images
that have come out from that particular
facility
is what's happening inside acceptable to
you
and when is this going to be fixed is
that's a serious question right
is it acceptable to me come on that's
why
i'm moving a thousand of those kids out
quickly
that's why i got fort bliss opened up
that's why i've been working from the
moment
this started to happen to try to find
additional access
for children to be able to safely not
just children but particularly children
to be able to safely be housed while we
follow through on the rest of what's
happening
that is totally unacceptable
it's time to move on i think um ken
thank you mr president i want to ask you
about afghanistan
you face a may first deadline for the
withdrawal
of u.s troops from that country
as a candidate in foreign affairs you
wrote
that it is past time to end these
forever wars
can you commit to the american people
that by may 2nd
the u.s will no longer have forces
in afghanistan answer is that
it's going to be hard to meet the may
one deadline
just in terms of tactical reasons hard
to get those troops out
so what we've been doing what i've been
doing and what
secretary blinken has been doing has
been
we've been meeting with our allies those
other nations that have nato allies who
have troops in afghanistan as well
and uh and if we leave we're going to do
so in a safe
and orderly way uh we're in consultation
i say with our allies and partners
and how to proceed and secretary blinken
is meeting in brussels this week with
our nato
allies particularly those who have
forces there
and general austin is just met with
kyani and i'm waiting for the briefing
on that he is the
the the leader in afghanistan and kabul
and there's a un-led process that's
beginning
shortly on how to mechanically
get people how to end this war but
it is not my intention to stay there for
a long time
but the question is how and in what
circumstances do we
meet that agreement that was made by
president trump to
leave under a deal that looks like it's
not being able to be worked out to begin
with
how how's that done but we are not
staying
a long time
do you think it's possible that we will
leave the question is
when we leave sorry do you believe
though it's possible we could have
troops there next year
i i can't picture that being the case
all right let's see if that happens okay
uh kristen
thank you very much mr president given
the conditions that were just laid out
at the migrant facilities
at the u.s border will you commit to
allowing journalists
to have access to the facilities that
are
overcrowded moving forward i will commit
when my plan very shortly is underway
to let you have access to not just them
but other facilities as well
be able to have access to the facilities
we've obviously
been allowed to be inside one how soon i
haven't seen
the facilities in which children are
packed
together to really give the american
people a chance to see that will you
commit to transparency on this issue i
will commit to transparency
and as soon as i am in a position to be
able to implement what we're doing
right now and one of the reasons i
haven't gone down
i've all my my chief folks have gone
down is i don't want to become
the issue i don't want to be you know
bringing
all the secret service and everybody
with me to get in the way
so this is being set up and you'll have
full access to everything once we get
this thing moving
okay just to be clear how soon will that
be mr president
i don't know to be clear
for everything that's happening at the
border now i hear you talking a lot
about the past
administration you decided to roll back
some of those policies did you move too
quickly to roll back what i'm sorry
policies did you move too quickly to
roll back
some of the executive orders of your
predecessor first of all
all the policies are underway were not
helping at all
did not slow up the amount of
immigration and there's many people
coming
and rolling back the policies of
separating children from their
from their mothers i make no apology for
that rolling back the policies of
remaining in mexico sitting on the edge
of the rio grande and the muddy
circumstance with not enough to eat i
make no apologies for that
i make no apologies for ending programs
that did not exist
before trump became president
that have an incredibly negative impact
on
the law international law
as well as on human dignity and so i
make no apologies for that i'll just ask
you about foreign policy mr president
overnight we learned that north korea
here's peter ducey
ballistic missiles will he be called on
actions will you take
and what is your red line on north korea
let me say that number one
u.n resolution 1718 was violated by
those particular missiles that were
tested
number one we're consulting with our
allies
and partners and
there will be responses if they choose
to escalate
we will respond accordingly but i'm also
prepared
for some form of diplomacy
but it has to be conditioned upon
the end result of denuclearization
so uh um
that's what we're doing right now
consulting with our allies just
very quickly you only got another hour
now okay diplomacy
can you define what you mean and former
president obama warned
the incoming president trump that north
korea
was the top foreign policy issue that he
was washing is that how you assess
the crisis in north korea yes
okay all right wow
nancy cbs
thank you very much mr president i want
to go back to voting rights
and as yamiche mentioned republican
legislatures across the country
are working to pass bills that would
restrict voting particularly
democrats fear impacting minority voters
and young voters the very people who
helped to get you
elected in november are you worried
that if you don't manage to pass
voting rights legislation that your
party is going to lose seats and
possibly lose control
of the house and the senate in 2022.
what i'm worried about is how unamerican
this whole initiative is it's sick
it's sick deciding in some states that
you cannot
bring water to people standing in line
waiting to vote deciding that
you're going to end voting at five
o'clock when working people are just
getting off work right deciding that
there will be no absentee ballots under
the most
rigid circumstances it's all designed
and i'm going to spend my time
doing three things one trying to figure
out how to
pass the legislation passed by the house
number one number two educating the
american public
the republican voters i know
find this despicable republican voters
folks out in the outside this white
house
i'm not talking about the the elected
officials
i'm talking about voters voters
and so i'm convinced that we'll be able
to stop this because it is the most
pernicious thing
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
i mean this is gigantic what they're
trying to do
and it cannot be sustained and do
everything on my power along with my
friends in the house and the senate to
keep that from
from becoming the law is there anything
else
you can do about it besides passing
legislation
the answer is yes but i'm not going to
lay out a strategy
in front of the whole world in you now
then on a related note have you decided
whether you are going to run for
re-election
in 2024 you haven't set up a re-election
campaign yet as your predecessor
by this time my predecessor need to need
it too
my predecessor oh god i missed it
no my plan is to run for re-election
that's my
oh i like that on on one other note
on bipartisanship my predecessor mitch
mcconnell
says you have only spoken to each other
once since you took office
and that you have moved far left since
taking off
oh yeah do you see it really far left
have you
rejected bipartisanship no i haven't at
all but meeting
when's the last time a president invited
the opposite party down
at least a half a dozen times to talk
about issues everything from
how we work i'm we're working with a
group of 20
members of the senate right now in-house
on how we
re-establish our ability to make
computer chips and how we get ahead of
the game
how we can work together we're working
together on a bunch of things but look
i know mitch well mitch knows me well i
would expect mitch to say exactly what
he said
but this is a matter of making sure that
i would like republican
elected republican support but what i
know i have now is i have
electoral support from republican voters
right voters agree with what i'm doing
and so unless mitch says the last thing
i did this
last piece of legislation is so far left
well then you ought to take a look at
his party
over 50 of them must be over that edge
as well
because they support what i did right uh
okay um where am i here
let me see caitlyn
thank you very much mr president i have
a question for you but first i'd like to
follow up on
a question from yamiche and that's on
the floor that counts as a question but
go ahead
okay i'll make it quick no no you can't
uh regarding the filibuster at john
lewis's funeral president barack obama
said he believed the filibuster was a
relic of the jim crow era
do you agree yes if not why not abolish
it if it's a relic of the jim crow era
successful electoral politics is the art
of the possible
let's figure out how we can get this
done
and move in the direction of
significantly changing the abuse of even
the filibuster rule
first it's been abused from the time it
came into being
by an extreme way in the last
20 years let's deal with the abuse first
you're moving closer to eliminating the
filibuster is that correct
i answered your question you also just
made some news by saying that you are
going to run for re-election i said that
is my expectation
so is that a yes that you are running
for re-election look i'm i don't know
where you guys come from man i've never
been able to travel i'm a great
respecter of fate i've never been able
to plan four and a half three and a half
years ahead for certain
and if you do if you do run will vice
president harris be on your ticket i
really expect that to be the case she's
doing a great job she's a great partner
she's a great partner and do you believe
you'll be running against former
president trump
oh come on i don't even think about i
don't have i have no idea
i have no idea it'll be a republican
party
[Laughter]
that's actually pretty funny the party
might be done by then
the way i view things i become a great
respecter of fate in my life i set a
goal of this in front of me to get
things done
for the people i care most about that's
actually not bad which republican do you
expect to run against i don't know that
there will be any republicans
i want to change the paradigm i want to
change the paradigm
we start to reward work not just wealth
i want to change the paradigm if you
notice didn't you find it kind of
interesting that
my republican friends were worried about
that
the cost and the taxes that had to be
had if there is any tax to be had as
they talk about it
and dealing with the the act that we
just passed
which puts money in people's pockets
ordinary people
do you hear them complain when they
passed close to two trillion dollar
trump tax cut
of 83 percent going to the top one
percent
do you hear them talk about that at all
i love the fact that they found
this whole idea of concern about
the federal budget it's kind of amazing
when the federal budget is saving
people's lives
they don't think it's such a good idea
when the federal budget is feathering
the nest of the wealthiest americans
90 of the fortune 500 companies making
billions of dollars not paying a cent in
taxes
reducing taxes to a point that
people who are making you know if you're
a husband and wife
a school teacher and a cop you're paying
at a higher rate than the average person
making a billion dollars a year is
something's wrong their newfound concern
i'm concerned look i meant what i said
when i ran and a lot of you still think
i'm wrong and i
respect that right i'm running for three
reasons
to restore the soul dignity honor
honesty transparency
to the american political system
two to rebuild the backbone of this
country
the middle class hard-working people and
people struggling
in the middle class they built america
right
and unions built them wow
the third reason i said i was running
was to unite the country
and generically speaking all of you said
no you can't do that
well i've not been able to unite the
congress but i've been uniting the
country
based on the polling data
we have to come together we have to
so from my perspective you know it's uh
to me it's about just
you know getting out there putting one
foot in front of the other and just
trying to make things better for people
just hard-working people people get up
every morning and just want to figure
out
how to put food in the table for their
kids to be able to have a little bit of
breathing room
being able to have make sure that they
go to bed not staring to the ceiling
because my dad didn't wonder whether
since he didn't have health insurance
what happens if mom gets sick or he got
sick
these are basic things basic things
and i'm of the view that the vast
majority of people
including registered republicans by and
large
share that that that same that same view
that same
sense of what is uh you know what's
appropriate
justin doesn't sink bloomberg
uh thanks mr president i want to ask
about your relationship with china now
that you've been on
office for a couple months there's
obviously the meeting in alaska that
was a little theatrical and there's the
continued human rights abuses so today
i'm wondering
are you more likely than you were when
you came into office to maintain
tariffs on china are you considering
banning imports
of forced labor products and would you
consider cutting off us
investment or chinese access to uh
international payment systems
look
[Music]
each specifically legitimate
questions but they only
touch a
smidgen of what the relationship with
china really is about
i've known xi jinping for a long time
allegedly by the time i left office as
vice president i had spent more time
with chief
than any world leader had because
president obama and the chinese
president who
decided we should get to know one
another since it was inappropriate
for the president united states to spend
time with the vice president of another
country
but it was obvious he was going to
become the new leader of china
so i spent hours upon hours with him
alone with an interpreter my interpreter
and his
going into great detail and very very
straightforward
doesn't have a democratic with a small d
bone in his body
but he's a smart smart guy he's one of
the guys
like putin who thinks that autocracy is
the wave of the future democracy can't
function in an ever con
ever complex world so
when i was elected and he called to
congratulate me
i think to the surprise of the china
experts who were
his people on the call as well as mine
listening
we had a two-hour conversation
for two hours and
we made several things clear to one
another
i made it clear to him again it'd be
more interesting to have a two-hour
conversation in an hour
we're not looking for confrontation
although we know there will be steep
steep competition
two that we'll have strong competition
but will insist that china play by the
international rules
fair competition fair practices fair
trade
thirdly in order to compete effectively
i indicated
that we're going to deal with china
effectively and we're going to need
three things to do that
telling our people first we're going to
invest in american workers in american
science
i said that all through the campaign i
say it again and we're
i'm setting up my administration to be
able to do that which is that
you know back in the 60s we used to
invest a little over two percent of our
entire
entire gdp in pure research
and investment in science today it's 0.7
percent
i'm going to change that we're going to
change that
the future lies in who can in fact
own the future as it relates to
technology quantum computing a whole
range of things
including the medical fields and so
what i'm gonna do is make sure we invest
closer to two percent one of the reasons
why
i've set up the the p
ab the president's board with scientists
and like again
is uh we're going to invest in medical
research
cancer alzheimer's diabetes the things
industries of the future artificial
intelligence quantum computing
biotech and we're going to make real
investments
china is out investing us by a long shot
because their plan is to own that future
the third the second thing we're going
to do is we're going to reestablish our
alliances and i've been very clear with
him
it's not anti-chinese and
we've talked about it i want to make
sure that for example later today after
this as a matter of fact
shortly after this um which is fine
we've been going close to an hour
i'm happy he may have to go somewhere
but
the the performance has been up and down
but it's actually been great insight
into how joe
biden balances idealism versus
pragmatism what his priorities are his
views on poor and
foreign policy it's actually been super
informative with some lulls in
performance for sure
we got the chinese attention that's not
why i did it
i met with our allies and how we're
going to hold china accountable in the
region
australia india japan the united states
the so-called quad
because we have to have
democracies working together
before too long i'm going to have i'm
going to invite
you might be shocked to know the
question was are you holding bitcoin
and so we're going to make it clear that
in order to deal with these things
we are going to hold china accountable
to follow the rules
follow the rules whether it relates to
the
south china sea or the north china sea
or the agreement made on taiwan or a
whole range of other things
and the third thing and the thing that i
i admire about dealing with she is he
understands he makes no
no pretense about not understanding what
i'm saying anymore i knew him
i pointed out to him no leader can be
sustained in his position
or her position unless they represent
the values of the country
and i said as and mr president as i've
told you before
americans value the notion of freedom
america values human rights we don't
always live up to our expectations
but it's a value system we are founded
on that principle
and as long as you and your country
continues to so blatantly violate human
rights
we are going to continue in an
unrelenting way
to call through the attention of the
world and make it clear
make it clear what's happening and
he understood that i made it clear that
no american president at least one did
but
no american president ever backed down
from speaking out of what's happening to
the uyghurs
what's happening in hong kong what's
happening in
in in country that's who we are
the moment a president walks away from
that as the last one did
is the moment we begin to lose our
legitimacy around the world
it's who we are so i
see stiff competition with
china china has an overall goal
and i don't criticize them for the goal
but they have an overall goal to become
the leading country in the world
the wealthiest country in the world and
the most powerful country in the world
that's not going to happen on my watch
because the united states is going to
continue to grow
and expand sorry just to follow up on
the meeting of democracies is that where
you
expect in a multilateral way to make
these decisions about
sanctions or no that's not going to make
decisions that's where i make sure we're
all on the same page
on the same page look i predict to you
your children or grandchildren are going
to be doing their
doctoral thesis on issue of
who succeeded autocracy or democracy
because that is what is at stake
not just with china look around the
world
we're in the midst of a fourth
industrial revolution
of enormous consequence will there be
middle class
how will people adjust to these
significant changes in science and
technology
the environment how will they do that
and our democracy is equipped
because all the people get to speak to
compete
it is clear absolutely clear
and most of the scholars i dealt with at
penn agree with me
around the country that this is a battle
between
the utility of democracies in the 21st
century
and autocracies if you notice
you don't have russia talking about
communism anymore
it's about an autocracy
demand decisions made by
a leader of a country that's what's at
stake here we've got to prove democracy
works
mr president sorry i know you have
another chance to address
uh the tragedies in georgia and
colorado you had said to stay tuned for
actions that you might take
on gun control wondering if you've made
a decision either about
sending the manufacturer liability bill
that you promised on day one to capitol
hill
or executive actions like going after
ghost guns
or giving money to cities and states to
battle gun control
all the above it's a matter of timing as
you've all
observed
successful presidents better than me
have been successful in large part
because they know how to time what
they're doing
order it decide priorities
what needs to be done the next major
initiative is
and i'll be announcing it friday in
pittsburgh in detail
is to rebuild
the infrastructure both physical and
technological
so he's going to do infrastructure next
this has been the question so that we
can compete
and create significant numbers
of really good paying jobs
really good paying jobs i think this is
the right move
and some of you have been around long
enough to know
that used to be a great republican goal
initiative
as i said last week i think that the tax
reform is politically tough right now
i think infrastructure is a far better
bet we are now ranked what 85th in the
world in infrastructure i mean
look the future rests on whether or not
we have
the and it makes republican look
republicans look worse for opposing it
also
ports that you can get out of quickly so
businesses decide
some of you when you're if you're ever
local reporters
and you found your governor or mayor
trying to attract business to your
community what's the first thing the
business asked
what's the closest access access to an
interstate highway
how far am i from freight rail
is the water is the water available is
enough water available for me to conduct
my business
all the things that relate to
infrastructure we have
somewhere i i asked the staff to write
it down for me and they did not for this
but
for a longer discussion we have
somewhere
in terms of infrastructure we have we
rank 13th globally in infrastructure
china is investing three times more in
infrastructure than the united states is
bridges more than one-third of our
bridges 231
000 of them need repairs some
are physical safety risks or
preservation work
one in five miles of our highways and
major roads are in poor condition
that's 186 000 miles of highway
aviation 20 percent of all flights
20 of all flights weren't on time
resulting in 1.5 million hours
lost in production 6
to 10 million homes in america still
have
lead pipes servicing their water lines
we have over a hundred thousand well
heads that are not
capped methane
what are we doing and by the way
we can put as many pipe fritters
and miners on us to work capping those
wells
at the same price that they were charged
to dig those wells
so i i just find it um
frustrating frustrating talk about
last point i'll make in the
infrastructure and i apologize for
spending more time on it but is that
if you think about it
um it's the place
where we will be able to significantly
increase american productivity
at the same time providing
really good jobs for people
but we can't build back to what they
used to be
we have to build the environments our
global warming's already done
significant damage
the roads that used to be above the
water level
didn't have to worry about where the
drainage was
now you've got to rebuild them three
feet higher because it's not going to go
back to what it was before
only get worse unless we stop it
there's so much we can do look at all
the schools
in america most of you live in the
washington area now
but in your hometowns i don't know where
you're all from
[Music]
how many schools where the kids can't
drink the water out of the fountain
how many schools are still in a position
where there's asbestos
how many schools in america we're
sending our kids to
don't have adequate ventilation
how many homes buildings
office complexes are wasting
billions of barrels of oil over time
because they can't hold in
the heat or the air conditioning
because this leaks through the windows
that are so porous
and the connections it's amazing
so there's so much we can do that's good
stuff
makes people healthier and creates good
jobs
and uh i think that uh i got one more
question here
and janet uh from univision no question
for peter ducey
president we too have been reporting at
the border and just like cecilia we ran
into a pair of siblings who came in on
monday
were detained by cbp had the phone
number for their mother who lives in the
u.s
we have contacted the mother that's the
only way they know her
kids are here because cbp today thursday
has not contacted that mother
so when can we expect your promise of
things getting better
with contacting and expediting well
they're already getting better but
they're going to get
real i got a whole hell of a lot better
real quick and we're going to hear some
people leaving
okay we can get this done oh firings
we're going to get it done
i had a long meeting with the entire
team and several cabinet level officers
the other night we're going to be moving
within the next uh
within the next week over a hundred
thousand i mean
a a thousand people out of uh
the border patrol into safe secure
beds and facilities we're gonna
significantly ramp up we're already out
there contacting
everyone from getting some of the
employees at hhs there's a lot of them
doing other things and move them into
making those calls
we're in the process of rearranging and
providing for the personnel
needed to get that done but i admire the
fact that
you were down there you're making the
calls yourself
it's real the next thing that has to
happen though as you well know
has to happen we have to be some
certitude that this
is the actually mom dad or whomever
and there's ways to do that there's ways
to do that a little bit like determining
whether or not
you got the right code for your credit
card uh you know
what what was your dog's name kind of
thing i'm being a bit facetious
and also seeking harder data from dna
speaking of the dogs to birth
certificates which takes longer
so i want to do this as as
quickly as humanly possible and as
safely as possible
well no treating the root cause causes
in latin america doesn't change things
overnight how do you realistically and
physically keep these families from
coming to the us
when things will not get better in their
countries right away
uh-oh he's getting closer i can't
guarantee that
but i know you know that whole thing the
journey of a thousand miles starts with
the first step
ancient proverbs apocryphal maybe
you have serious it's not like
somebody's sitting on a
hand you table in guatemala i mean in in
somewhere in mexico or
in guadalupe saying i got a great idea
let's sell everything we have give it to
a coyote
have them take our kids across the
border into the desert where they don't
speak the language
won't that be fun let's go
that's not how it happens people don't
want to leave
when my great-grandfather got in a
coffin ship in the irish sea
expectation was was he was going to live
long enough
on that ship to get to the united states
of america but they left because what
the brits have been doing
they were in real real trouble they
didn't want to leave
but they had no choice so you've got
we can't i can't guarantee we're going
to solve everything
but i can guarantee we can make
everything better
we can make it better we can change the
lives of so many people and the other
thing i want to point out to you
and i hope you point out i realize it's
much more heart-wrenching and it is
to deal with a five and six and
seven-year-old but you went down there
and you saw the vast majority of these
children 70 percent are 16 years old
17 years old and mostly males that make
it
doesn't make it good better and
different but the idea
that we have tens of thousands of kids
in these god-awful facilities that are
really little babies crying all night
there's some that's true
that's why we got to act and yesterday i
asked
my team both the director of the two
agencies as well as others
i asked them what would they in fact and
i asked their opinion because they're
the experts but i said
focus on the most vulnerable immediately
but there's no reason why in the next
month as people cross the border that
phone call can't be made in the first 48
hours
and began i may ask one last question
have you had any talks with
senate republicans who are threatening
this administration with not considering
the immigration legislation that was
passed in the house until the situation
at the border
has been resolved no because i know they
have to posture for a while
they sort of got to get out of their
system
um this is a uh um
[Music]
but i i'm ready to work with any
republican
who wants to help solve the problem
or make make the situation better but
folks
i'm going thank you very very much i
appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
and there goes uh president joe biden to
screaming
and yelling uh very very interesting
there was a good ques whoa
zuckerberg out of nowhere there was a
good question asked here i would love
your prediction about which clip fox
will obsess with i
expect on hannity i expect don jr
to tweet a compilation of silences where
biden is thinking what he wants to say
i would expect them to put them all back
to back
and create the appearance that biden was
essentially
in a haze and punch drunk the entire
time
that would be my my expectation now i
saw some people in the chat talking
amongst yourselves about something that
i think is a really good question
in these scenarios trump would say
everything's under control i'm going to
fix everything
completely and quickly period and
it was never believable to us but it
sort of projected a certain degree of
confidence joe biden
is speaking to people realistically
which is to say expecting me to fix
all of this stuff isn't realistic we can
improve
we're not going to completely resolve
all of these things a lot of these
things are decade long
decades long things why haven't i done
everything well because you've got to go
in order i can't do everything all at
once
there's going to be an order to things
and we have to prioritize it's
obviously completely realistic compared
to the trump approach
but what is going to be the perception
because you i'm my guess is right-wing
media is going to say
he didn't even commit to fixing every
problem he was asked about well no he's
telling the truth which is
he can't just do it all as an
authoritarian
trump either believed or pretended that
he could do everything
unilaterally as an authoritarian he
didn't we didn't believe it
but it counted as quote strength for
some people
on the right so i don't know what the
impact of that
um is necessarily going to be i want to
say
thank you not just to side to side jumps
who just grabbed the twitch subscription
but to everybody who signed up via
twitch the coupon code on my website
immoral 21 is done tomorrow
maxwell moody just used it on my website
michael jaramillo just used it kiret
dinza just used it
john stennett has signed up so many
great people
steve stock and heather coombs so i
really appreciate that
remember that we are on break next week
but then we're going to be back really
strongly really really strongly
and get me the video edits for the next
10 free membership contest you can
scroll back in the stream
to get the particulars on that and we
will see
everybody very very soon
you